it's
one week after planting now and i'm back
at the field here lee has gone off to
the beach
i've just come back from the beach so
for a few days nobody was watching the
crop
but it's now about the week after
planting and
it's the time to apply the first dose of
fertilizer because we didn't apply
a pre-plant application normally
during the first one or two weeks
or before planting you should apply a
little bit of nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium to help the crop establish
so that's what i will do now and
hopefully that will help then also with
the further
early stages then of course development
and tillering
so what i've done is just like i did
last year so i used the
fancy mobile phone application that we
have developed over many many years here
at erie
nutrient manager for rise and the only
difference is that
this year we have a new version for the
philippines version 2.2
so it has a few more refinements but
what it does
it walks you through a series of
relatively simple questions about your
field
what you've done previously in the
management how you
manage your organic metal what you do
with your crop residue
what your source of irrigation water is
what your variety is
in all of these things that basically
one way or another
influence the nutrient input output
budget
of this particular field and so we come
up with
field specific fertilizer recommendation
so i can do this directly here in the
field on this
smartphone or i can do it before that
at home either on a smartphone or on a
tablet computer or on a desktop computer
that's actually what i've done so before
i came here
i ran through this and i came up with
actually two fertilizer recommendations
because if you may
remember one half of the field this over
there
we planted with an inward variety and
this half
we planted with a hybrid so this is all
normal and well-known principles of crop
nutrition and rice
that are reflected in this software and
what i really like with it in particular
is that it comes out with
a very concrete prescription so it's
printed
out and i'm given the the window
of when i should apply it pretty
precisely
and i'm also given a very clear
recommendation of what to apply
so my main challenge is now to apply it
and also make sure that i apply it
relatively uniformly
so i have a bag of fertilizer here which
is
14 14 14
14 nitrogen fourteen percent p205
fourteen percent k200 that's my if you
wish startup fertilizer for this
uh first application and
basically since our recommendation is
four bags per hectare and our field is
about a quarter of a hectare it means
i have to spread this one bag more or
less uniformly over this field
and what i will do is if i have a little
bit left over i will put it on the
hybrid strip
not on the invert strip that's the only
adjustment i will make
other than that it should probably not
take me more than
maybe half an hour i hope what i learned
last year is there are a couple of
tricks
to apply this one is that
i've you know imagined to divide this
strip into four
strips each of them about six meters
wide
but the the trick is not to walk in the
middle of each but a little bit to the
side because
that way you can throw better and then
the other
uh tip they gave me last year was that
you have to really
swing with your arm wide and keep
walking and not sort of looking down
and try to sprinkle it like powdered
sugar you just go and throw
yeah here is something i wanted to show
you because it's always bothered me you
know when you apply
fertilizer in most traditional rice
growing systems and you don't have a
machine basically this is what you see
so you have tiny little young rice
plants here
in this case because spaced quite wide
because we use the
mechanical transplanter and
they're not really at a stage where they
have a big root system that can capture
much of the nutrient supply and then you
throw this by hand
broadcast and you see where most of the
fertilizer ends up
in this case on the surface in between
so even if i had incorporated it would
still be in between
so i keep wondering wouldn't it be nice
if
on that planting machine that we had
we would have been able to already apply
some of the fertilizer
at least disperse those right away
closer to the road
so that it can be captured by the plants
and doesn't end up
fertilizing the soil something has
always been bothering me
because i'm pretty sure that with this
kind of system here
our efficiency is not as good as it
could be
so hopefully in the future those
machines can be improved for this
purpose particularly even the small one
they used
you